العالم ما هو أكثر نقيضًا
للموسيقى صمت المدن المدمرة وقتل
الناس.
أطفالنا يرسمون صواريخ لا تطلق
النار على النجوم أصيب أكثر من 400
طفل بجروح وتوفي 153 طفلاً
ولن يروهم أبدًا وهم يرسمون
والدينا سعداء للاستيقاظ
في الصباح.  الملاجئ من القنابل ولكن في
الحياة لا يعرف أحباؤنا ما إذا كنا سنكون
معًا مرة أخرى ، فإن العالم لا يسمح لنا
باختيار حياة من يبقى في
صمت داخلي
يرتدي موسيقيونا الدروع الواقية من الرصاص بدلاً من
البدلة الرسمية وهم يخطئون إلى جرحىهم في
المستشفيات حتى  لأولئك الذين لا يستطيعون
سماعهم ولكن الموسيقى ستنتشر على
أي حال ،
نحن ندافع عن حريتنا في العيش لحب
الصوت على أرضنا ، فنحن نحارب روسيا
التي تجلب الصمت الرهيب
بقنابلها ، ويشعر صمت الموت بالصمت
مع موسيقاك اليوم.  لإخبار قصتنا
أخبر الحقيقة عن الحرب على
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بك على التلفزيون ، ادعمنا
بأي طريقة ممكنة ولكن ليس الصمت وبعد ذلك
سيأتي السلام
إلى جميع
مدننا في العالم  د يدمر
التموج والآخرون هم أساطير بالفعل ولكن
لدي حلم منهم يعيشون
وحرة مثلك على مسرح الأحلام
[موسيقى]
أنت